horizon forbidden west is the
long-awaited sequel to horizon zero dawn
we'll once again be following humanity's
champion eloy as she journeys toward the
wreckage of the american west coast to
try and save the world here's everything
you need to know about horizon forbidden
west
set six months after the events of
horizon zero dawn the world is ending
again between deranged machines fierce
storms and a blight ripping through the
planet and destroying its crops the
remaining humans are struggling to get
by
eloy a former outcast needs to get to
the bottom of what's going on by heading
to the forbidden west gathering allies
and exploring the remains of earth to
help uncover the secrets that will save
it on her journey she'll travel to new
areas like san francisco and las vegas
as well as meet new tribes like the
uttaru farmers who work the dying land
and the tanakh a tribe driven by war and
combat and try and make them work
together to try and save the world
it's not as simple as just making nice
though as a rebel tanakh tribe will
cause problems for everyone and a
greater threat looms over them all
ashley burch and lance riddick reprise
their roles as nora outcast eloy and the
mysterious silence who seems to have his
own plans and joining the cast are
angela bassett playing tanakh rebel
regala and carrie anne moss who plays a
mysterious character called tilde if you
want to get caught up on the story
before forbidden west make sure to
subscribe we've got a full story recap
coming your way and believe me you'll
need it
horizon forbidden west aims to build on
what came before in horizon zero dawn
with similar mechanics and combat but
gorilla is expanding on elo's suite of
abilities and equipment to show that
she's a more competent and experienced
fighter than she was in the first game
at the same time the studio has said
that it wants to keep her abilities
relatively realistic and human ailoy
obtains a pull caster for traversal that
allows her to grapple onto points around
the world and while she can climb more
freely and even wall jump now she's
still a human and will struggle with
particularly steep inclines the
polecaster also acts as a winch meaning
you'll be able to use it to rip open
vents to create more paths for you to
travel she can also swim underwater
thanks to a new diving mask and as in
the first game aloy can override
machines to ride around the world in
forbidden west she's able to use even
more machine types as mounts to make
getting down as fun as going up she can
use the shield wing a new item that acts
as a glider to help get around the map
totally new to the game is the workbench
where eloi can put her crafting skills
to good use to upgrade her outfit and
weapons which can then be customized
with mod slots as well as unlockable
perks you'll be able to equip outfits
and gear with passive stat boosts and
perks which when coupled with the new
skills in the redesigned skill tree
should help you prepare for anything the
forbidden west might throw at you combat
has also seen some tweaks with gorilla
wanting to encourage player choice and
experimentation when they find
themselves up against the ferocious
metal beasts that roam the forbidden
west the machines have gotten their own
upgrades with an emphasis on better ai
and traversal tools that will let them
jump climb swim and look for shortcuts
to head you off ailoy is not the only
person who can ride machines either
you'll be coming up against other
factions who can use the machines as
mounts there are also new machines that
you'll come up against like the
ginormous tremor tusk who looks and acts
like a giant war elephant there's also
the rollerback the pterodactyl-esque sun
wing and the giant slitherfang
snakes why's it always gotta be snakes
when you encounter enemies you'll be
able to sneak away but enemies will
remember where they saw you and start to
search if you're not where they expected
to find you there are also new
unlockable abilities called valor surges
they will absolutely help you out if
things get a little bit hairy these new
skills have three levels and can be
powered up by removing components on
enemies or by hitting their weak points
the higher the level of your valor surge
the more damage you'll deal missions can
consist of contracts to complete certain
types of tasks like gathering a
particular material from fallen machines
and of course the return of ruins and
cauldrons forbidden west will also
include a new warrior arena that will
test your combat skills
horizon forbidden west will be available
on both playstation 4 and playstation 5.
more on that in a second but as of the
writing of this video it's not confirmed
for pc we think it's a safe bet to say
it may come to pc eventually as
playstation has started to put first
party games like day's gone god of war
and of course the original horizon onto
the platform in a recent sony blog q a
interview playstation boss hermann hulst
asserted that the company intends to
further invest in the pc space though
most of the game has been shown on ps5 a
set of ps4 screens released by gorilla
shows the game looking awfully nice on
that platform as well given that horizon
zero dawn was among the more stunning
games for the ps4 gorilla may be able to
push the hardware to its limit and make
it an impressive showpiece there too
speaking to game informer the game's
director has tried to assuage fears
about the ps4 version he said a lot of
the development has taken place on the
playstation 4 and a lot of play testing
is also done on playstation 4. so we are
ensuring that owners of that console
will have a great experience and that
the game will look fantastic well let's
hope so gorilla has detailed some of the
upgrades we can expect to see on the
playstation 5 version such as the
mapping of accurate facial expressions
and body movements but the studio says
that the playstation 4 version is not
compromised on ps5 you'll also get all
the advantages of sony's shiny new
console like faster load times thanks to
the high speed solid state drive and
targeted 60 frames per second in
performance mode the game will also make
use of the dual sense controller's
haptic feedback as you journey and fight
through the world as well as the
resistance on the adaptive triggers
making you feel like you're actually
drawing the string on your bow it'll
also make use of the ps5's tempest 3d
audio tech
[Music]
so far no dlc or microtransactions have
been announced for forbidden west you
might remember that zero dawn did get a
meaty dlc expansion called the frozen
wilds which opened up a new snowy region
to explore and introduce new factions
hopefully gorilla will do something
similar for forbidden west and will
obviously have all the news if it
happens
forbidden west was originally set for
launch in 2021 but slipped into early
2022 that delay actually had an
unexpected impact on its price sony had
previously announced that all games in
the ps5 launch window would receive a
free upgrade from the ps4 to ps5
versions but as horizon slipped outside
this window that deal wasn't valid
anymore after fan outcry sony quickly
reversed its decision meaning that if
you buy forbidden west on ps4 for 60
dollars you can upgrade to the ps5
version for free seems like a great deal
to me as the ps5 version by itself costs
70
if you want all the bells and whistles
including digital soundtrack art book
comic and extra in-game resources like
weapons and outfits as well as photo
mode extras then the digital deluxe
edition for ps4 and 5 will set you back
80 bucks
we have a ton of horizon content on the
horizon
like graphics comparisons tips
walkthroughs and of course our review so
make sure you like this video and
subscribe so you don't miss out thanks
for watching
[Music]